this looks like a regular visit for
coffee but very little in the lives of
leeuwen zoo and one selling is normal
woman's leave here baby whenever we go
out we are followed sometimes they won't
let us leave the house many of our
friends were scared to talk to us
especially at the beginning on July 9th
2015 Lee and Wong's husbands were taken
away they are human rights lawyers two
of the 250 lawyers rounded up by police
as part of President Xi Jinping's
campaign to crack down on critics and
dissidents the ones who knows what it's
like when they come in the middle of the
night break down your daughter and take
your husband away no one else
understands neither has had any contact
with their husband since onion drew home
six months later we got a letter
informing us our husbands were charged
with undermining the authority of the
state that's a very serious crime in
China and the punishment is severe but
we were relieved because it meant they
were still alive
the two women do not know what their
husbands may have been through but Chen
gang gang himself a lawyer recently
published transcripts of conversations
with a client Xie Yang a human rights
lawyer who says he endured torture in
detention and involved sleep deprivation
beatings and spending hours in painful
positions in the past few years have
seen a massive setback for human rights
in China under the current government
force protecting defendants have become
entirely worthless the fathers of these
children Jame and tension could face 10
year prison sentences Jame saw her
father being seized tension was with his
grandparents when the police came his
mother
Leo and Zhu told him his father was on a
business trip at first but eventually
told him the truth he said okay I'll eat
plenty and go to bed on time
and when I'm big and strong I'll fight
the monsters he thinks monsters have
gotten his father for now all the women
can do to help their husbands is try to
draw attention to the plight of lawyers
fighting for human rights in China